au niveau c'est parti c'est parti c'est
parti on y est bonsoir si vous nous
rejoignez sur sur des gones al tv donc
poursuivre ce blitz ce soir donc on va
se faire le blitz annoncé par la
fédération française d'échecs koala qui
propose de jouer ses beats en ligne et
donc qui qui permet de récupérer pas mal
de joueurs français même beaucoup
puisque la semaine dernière donc on
était 1200 je crois à peu près ce qui
est vraiment bien même s'il ya un gros
tournoi qu'on a fait on a on était trois
mille je sais plus combien 3400 je crois
presque 4000 je sais plus bas le chiffre
exact mais c'était assez assez
impressionnant
alors on va faire un petit point quand
même sur sur notre notre état ici
statistiques pour pour le bit
voilà ces deux derniers jours là
vraiment on a fait une chute
spectaculaire de poèmes mais ça arrive
grosse grosse chute puisque en deux
jours on a perdu presque un peu plus de
100 points ou 1 c'est peu c'est vraiment
beaucoup
et alors hier on affine c'est une série
je crois que c'est la première fois que
ça m'arrive
on a fait une série de presque 10
parties d'affilée perdu peut-être faire
là on va voir un peu ce qu'on aura le
temps il est 24 il reste cinq minutes on
ne fait pas le temps bon elle fait tout
ça pour dire faux-pas ce faux pas se
démotiver pour sa partie perdue
d'affilée c'est vrai que c'est pas
facile mais bon c'est vrai aussi que
c'était là il y avait trois heures de
juin donc peut-être un peu trop 3 heures
2 heures ça commence à être bien on se
sera arrêtée à deux heures on était bien
et après on pompe où il aurait dû voir
que j'étais trop fatigué j'aurais dû
peut-être arrêter ou faire une pause et
laisser filer un peu le temps dans le
tournoi puisque on peut s'arrêter un peu
quand on veut
alors du coup on a un classement qui
était au plus haut à 2317 on est retombé
un petit peu puisqu'on à 2185 gens
n'aiment plus bas qui à 2119 bon alors à
noter sas et il faut saluer on a fait
des belles perfs 1 parce qu'on a battu
1-2 1472 en 2003
ça c'est des belles perfs ou très bien
et yazid anusara fait deux défaites
assez nos deux pires défaites avec yazid
là qu'elle 181 747
voilà qui nous qui nous piquent des
parties yazid là c'est bien c'est bien
parce qu'il a un classement qui met du
coup qui progresse on voit qu'ils
progressent en suivant de diagonale tv
il progresse et il me piquent des points
et l'audit dont donc voilà ben c'est
très bien bravo à yazid qui suit la
chaîne est qui qui me défie de temps en
temps et qui arrive à me piquer des
points et c'est très bien bravo à lui
alors qu'est ce qu'on va regarder il est
quelle heure 25
on a le temps alors à noter allez un
petit oeil sur la partie d'aujourd'hui
du jour de maxime vachier lagrave au
tournoi des candidates on a des
candidats ou y aller donc les 10
meilleurs joueurs du monde qui
s'affrontent pour désigner qui il va
jouer le champion du monde de magnus
carsen pour le titre de mondial
magnus carsen dont qui attend son
challenger et maxime vachier lagrave qui
était deuxième avant cette partie
réalise le meilleur résultat qu'on
pouvait espérer
puisqu'ils gagnent contre le leader du
tournoi c'est ils deviennent du coup le
seul jour et vaincu je crois de tête
peut-être grid choquer mais qui aussi
mais n'a fait que des nuls
c'est le deuxième mais en tout cas il a
marqué et il passe en tête surtout donc
le français passe en tête et alors
c'était une française il y avait aussi
ce qu'avait été joués voilà les prises
et puis est ce qu'on aura le temps de
regarder les 26 je suis pas sûr qu'on
ait le temps de regarder la partie en
détail mais bon à noter que donc la
gagner contre une française le français
a démoli la française ça c'est quand
même pas
donc bravo à un maxime pour cette
victoire exceptionnelle aujourd'hui qui
veut qui nous fait rêver d'un français
en finale des championnats du monde
maintenant et ça c'est du jamais vu
alors même depuis filer l'or puisque
pour philidor il était considéré comme
le meilleur n'y avait pas de championnat
du monde en proprement dit a pas gagné
vraiment son titre
sauf à faire un match contre stamm à qui
était considéré comme un très fort
joueur mais ne peut pas parler de
championnat du monde à l'époque
c'est arrivé beaucoup plus tard
l'organisation sérieuse de championnat
du monde c'est arrivé en 1800 1886 voilà
donc depuis en tout cas si dix doigts on
n'a jamais eu un français à ce niveau là
mondiale et maxime pourrait faire la
grosse grosse surprise de ce tour les
candidats en tout cas les parties pour
puisque à mi-tournoi y virent en tête en
ayant un impact psychologique sur
nepomniachi qui fait aussi un gros
tournoi mais qui après cette défaite
doit absolument tout remettre en
question
alors qu'il était très très bien avec un
groupe est en avance
justement sur maxime donc c'était la
partie a gagné et il l'a fait et ça
c'est ça c'est un signe
ça c'est un signe ça c'est un signe
morale c'est un signe sportif c'est un
signe extrêmement encourageants de
gagner laisser partie décisive là ça
prouve très grande qualité de champion
de maxime vachier lagrave
donc bravo à maxime et bien du coup
cocorico aujourd'hui de ce côté là et on
va revenir au tournoi alors on va
revenir au tour -
alors comment je vais trouver le lien
dans le tournant ffe du coup alors ça
c'est la grosse surprise parce que là
c'est le problème de lits thiès et que
la déforme trouve pas on sait pas trop
comment
comment ça marche pour trouver les trucs
je sais pas comment je suis inscrit ici
je sais c'est l'absurde doute mes moyens
mais j'ai pas envie de cliquer partout
salut à françois p ça lui a mis sion on
va suivre
on va faire un gros tournoi sur
nietzsche s alors pour la première fois
depuis quelques temps je stream surimi
échec qui est aussi une des chaînes de
canal tv c'est là même la chaîne
historique c'est là où l'essentiel du
catalogue historique un diagonale t
entre 98 et 2007 qui a été produit a été
mis en ligne avec notre partenaire
imineo donc c'est une chaîne que je
continue d'alimenter de temps en temps
puisqu'il n'y a pas de raison de ne pas
lui donner des contenus nouveaux aussi
voilà donc vous pouvez vous abonner
aussi à la chaîne diagonale tv il ya des
contenus plus fréquent est éliminé au
chèque il ya tout le catalogue anciens
et ça changera pas il ya pas de raison
c'est très bien là avec nos excellents
partenaires de dee mineo voilà
poursuivre beaucoup de vidéos d'échec il
n'y a pas que de nouvelles tv sur cette
chaîne yad'autres d'autres contenus
c'est une excellente chaîne et de temps
en temps il ya quelques string monatélé
que je fais sur une mine aux échecs
voilà il se tombe celui là alors ouais
ouais il faut que j'aille comme ça
ah bon ça y est il ya fait feu résume un
qu'est-ce qui se passe alors il ya les
caisses qui rame un peu comme hier il ya
eu hier sarah leah sahara mais un peu et
c'est parti oh là là ils sont partis
sans annoncer bon aller où l'amateur fou
qui aima turfoo attention je suis pas
qui s'est glissée fort il ya 2500 m 9
bon là on est parti pour la perdre celle
là est ce qu'on va l'avoir comme maxime
ne sera pas faire donc on va essayer de
la faire avec
on y enseigne 3 je crois que c'est 5,3
csn +3 ya trois secondes par coup en
plus à l'est
khalef trois matches où il faut des
trois ce qu'il faut faire et chez cauet
peut-être on va faire échec
5 je sais pas si c'est très bon alors
ouais c'est en tout cas l'avis des deux
cas les 17 que livre iii semble bien
matters fout en l'air de when de bien
connaître son affaire il va mettre son
cavalier 1,4 il va nous embêter
il va nous embêter les mateurs fou alors
qu'est-ce que non ça me plaît pas parce
qu il danse il ya là il faudrait que je
puisse jouer 3 mais comme j'ai mis mon
cavalier c'est un tout petit peu
embêtant bon on va peut-être sortir le
fou d'abord à léon sur le fou c'est le
cas l'hiver le 4 on va prendre un set
sans doute voilà et maintenant
et maintenant peut-être ont baissé de
tak et sur le côté
aussi souhaite alors je afp trois procès
de consolider ses quatre ans j'ai pas
envie de prendre parce qu'il placerait
sont fous au centre il serait très bien
placés en d5
alors ouais j'aime pas j'aime pas cette
position déjà je me suis un peu cliché
comment ni dans le sud alors tour à tour
est joué vous b4 qu'est-ce que je peux
faire ici si je fais qu'aller d2 il y
aura foule prendre qui on prend on
marque a les qualités 2 il peut aussi
jouer au foot et quatre peut-être ici
c'est vrai que ça a l'air pénible
peut-être il faut prendre le cas dans ce
cas
bijoux f3 possible aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
aïe ça j'aime pas ça j'aime pas du tout
commence à sentir le roussi l'ain alors
peut-être f3 prise là il prend les quais
chèque ça j'ai pas vu et ça gagne le
cavalier bon allez on l'arrête un bon
temps songé mais pas ma position c'est
pas grave ça soit une taie trop fort
pour nous là à 2500 et quelques bons
c'est ainsi on a pu la jouer mieux mais
je pense qu'on n'aurait pas on n'aurait
pas réussi on n'en ai pas réussi à le
déborder de toute façon donc je suis pas
je suis pas je vais pas en bide je vais
pas m'accrocher et déjà un mauvais début
de partie
voilà ne pas insister alors à l'eau à me
confiner bonsoir de à flot ou un salut à
flot alors
donc ça lui au spectateur de ce blitz
est fait floquer vie dure deux heures
donc on va perdre notre première partie
bon on a fait des bus passent pas bon là
on a fait une erreur stratégique assez
vite et je n'ai pas envie de j'avais pas
envie d'assister g4 c'est une
provocation ça alors des 5 6 et 6 pour
contrer ce fou il faut souvent pas
prendre ici parce que les blancs jouent
ces 4 maintenant je vais aussi six jeux
menace de prendre sans doute mais là on
prend tout simplement ça se casser la
tête et là par contre on va prendre ce
théâtre bah oui alors qu'alexis
certainement il faut sortir les pièces 6
alors d'un v6 d'un bep trois dames et
trois parents d'un bébé train d'un b 3 1
peut faire d'un v6 ou dames c'est cet
homme c'est cet ailleurs bien même ces
sept à l'hermione
allez on vient de jouer faut être cinq
fois pardon pouces et 5 c des bêtises et
forcément ça n'a pas marché et donc
qu'elle ait 17 certainement faut pas que
je me presse trop parce que on est en
cinq 5 3 donc il ya quand même plus
trois secondes par coup cinq minutes je
suis un peu sur les rythmes des derniers
tournois à jouer là qui était assez
rapide en trois minutes plus 2 secondes
alors ici bon ok
[Musique]
alors tombé 1 l'invité d'anne decis pour
voir comme au poker
allez qu'est ce que tu fais là en fait
je propose un échange de dames et en
même temps je menace aussi le pion à f2
puisque j'ai dame est fou dont il ya une
double menace
voilà et donc hélas il n'a pas vu il
fait une grosse erreur en fait ici il
faut prendre 2 on peut faire [ __ ] en
h4 sagan une pièce tout simplement
à noter que si maintenant ils ne
changent pas les dames je menace aussi
dame mat
ici donc il peut il peut prendre dans ce
cas là je reprendrai sans doute voilà
bon il prend pas donc je reprenais sans
doute pas mais là je vais prendre tout
simplement ce week-end les c5
lequel va les défendre et cette attaque
la tour et comment je vais prendre le
fou le pion des trois ans maintenant
avec échec
en plus ce cavalier presque intouchable
voilà il abandonne voilà on a trop
davantage on a gagné une pièce victoire
première victoire de tournoi aujourd'hui
ça fait plaisir
merci à pierre cardin pour la partie et
puis on poursuit notre petit chemin il
ya 1100 neuf joueurs
voilà donc c'est parti alors des quatre
a été joué cavalier pts 6 kelly f3 alors
l'if3 kf3 on va jouer avec g6 alors sans
ya plusieurs écoles et notamment il ya
des 5
ouais ça c'est l'école une fois f4 donc
foulé cette hockey dit rock
alors ici qu'est ce qu'on va faire mon
ami j'ai pas s'il faut pas jouer c6 ou
c5 csii peut-être prise c'est celle m'a
l'air pas mal à laisser 5 a l'air bien
et maintenant prise directement
ok j'ai envie de faire d'un v6
je vais faire d'un v6 pour toujours
faire ce qu'on a envie en tout cas la
rue lopez des sig aulas le très grand
père de la théorie du jeu d'échecs
disait ne rien faire contre la volonté
parce que tu es déjà un premier point
alors ici sans doute eu échec est tombé
5 ça marche pas parce que des saints qui
a là il ya le cavalier qui à la croire
ok bon mais on peut faire que les
dix-sept ici sans doute non
ou peut-être b6 abc c'est pas mal alors
attention iran si je fais b6 sur ab 4 je
crois que madame ait perdu pas de casier
on prend notre temps et pas besoin de se
presser quelle est celle qui a laissé
six cas les f 17,5 et g4 qu'elle et b17
allait se paraît le plus logique quand
même 17 semble très bien bonsoir
christopher bollard christopher benard
qui nous a rejoints salut christopher
alors d'am dam des 8
alors ça ça affaiblit un peu puisque le
pion c3 est faible ça c'était un peu
prématuré c'est un coût qui semble
actifs et sur sa force à la dame a bougé
on est d'accord mais la dame a une case
très sécure tout simplement des huîtres
revient la maison et même que le
problème d' avancer les pions c'est que
vous retrouvez des pions arriérés ici et
6e puis on s'avance contre celui là il
ya le pion des qui va être tout seul
bref ça crée des soucis ça crée des
petits problèmes là on doit pouvoir
jouer b6 c'est pas suivant c'est pas
suivre ses pas sûr donc qu'on va faire
plus tôt cavaliers prendre 5
je fais pas b6 parce que il y avait un
kbc 6 qui était un peu un tout petit peu
embêtant maintenant par contre b6
devrait fonctionner à peu près je pense
oui mais 6
et là les passes les noirs sont un tout
petit peu mieux à cause de ce pion c3
qui est un peu voilà up maintenant clio
iv et ça attaque derrière il y aura deux
pièces d'attaqué il peut prendre ici
d'abord il le fait pas donc là je pense
qu'il vaut mieux jouer 5 6e spare parts
dont m6 pour pouvoir peut-être joué 5
nous nous envolons ou pas alors au cinq
prises prise car les problèmes possibles
fou prend est jouable qui truc là quand
même
ouais ça passe à l'aps apparaît très
bien ça paraît très bien hercules notre
ami recul il recule
notre ami recule alors d'hommes qui
comprend où j'ai 4 x 6 x 6 peut-être
aussi ça paraît bien attention à fois ci
c'est pas mal aussi ça tacle cavaliers
detroit je passe sur soi très très bien
attention parce que m'ont fouillé pas
protégés en assises donc qu'il pourrait
y avoir des découvertes du cavalier bon
je veux être le fou ce que faut que je
bouge le fouet ce qu'il y'a pas mieux
on peut aussi tenter ça mais ça marche
pas faut éliminer ce cavalier peut-être
ou bien reculer le recul et le oui c'est
pas mal ça allait j'aime bien simplement
qu'elle ait des six avec l'idée de jouer
peut-être quatre pour garder des pions
liés et s'il prend j'ai deux groupes
sont liés au centre la voilà donc qui
prend pas on peut jouer que les ck
peut-être attaque un petit peu loin ici
ce qui va faire ce qu'il défend est ce
qu'ils défendent pas en tout cas lui
pose une question
c'est toujours bien de poser des
questions deux minutes 14 contre 3,48
mais là avec 5 + 3 je suis beaucoup
moins stressé que dans les yvelines ce
cas ou bien sûr trois secondes c'est
beaucoup pour jouer la fin de partie
c'est très très confortable dans b3 ou
qui donnent des trois dames et trompe
peut-être joué vous aussi ce tout
simplement on met le fou face à la dame
en défense du cavalier bon là on peut
peut-être prendre ou pas jouer b5 aussi
possible il va revenir avec son cavalier
peut prendre b2 on peut prendre le fou
prend le fou ça doit ça doit être une
bonne une bonne option
ça doit être une très bonne option
6 quand même avec c'est bien de placer
le fou là où ça peut faire mal
ici maintenant peut-être tour s'est vite
mettre les tours sur les colonnes aussi
commencé à mettre la pression là aussi
sur le sur le pion c'est en tout cas les
noirs une position passive 1 c'est sûr
ça suffit pas pour gagner mais ça donne
quand même quelques idées maintenant
alors peut-être un peu ici peut-être on
peut jouer dam dam des six donne 17 le 7
on peut aussi jouer fouet f5 attaque la
tour mais c'est pas c'est pas top top je
crois je vois pas trop quoi faire après
md si c'est bien faut 4 1 d'accord donc
là maintenant peut-être peut-être fait
cinq ans l'idée c'est de taper là dessus
comme ça le pion aux 3 est moins bien
défendus jour peut-être pu le faire
avant d'ailleurs
ah non je connais pas ce qu'il s'est dit
viens de jouer le fond wenjun fou se
fout un peu moins bien que celui-là a
priori puisqu'il est bien des scènes
notamment le gène pour contrôler
diagonale me semble-t-il aurait pu au
lieu de jouer d'amener si je pouvais
aussi je vais faut être cinq peut-être
fulham et je vois la tour qui bouge et
ff iii après je voyais pas trop quoi
faire après la ici les blancs peuvent
peut-être joué sécu alors où donc il est
seul il est tombé à l'est
l'emprunt on a gagné un groupe y ont
donc appris au centre attention que ça
va libérer ma tour sur la colonne f
mais il va aussi libérer ces pièces sur
sur mon pauvre petit pion des cinq a
alors ça qu'est ce qu'on fait ici c'est
qu'on prend des cartons pas prise prise
vous prend je suis pas sûr je préfère
jouer il faut être quatre tiens l'idée
c'est de faire pression sur age ii et
s'il joue g3 il peut toujours bien sûr
voilà un fou prend 6 me a toujours la
menace
ici sur sur age 2 ces quatre bons mais
ça veut dire qu'ils lâchent le h2 moi ça
va être égale un peu de perdre des 5
j'aime presque son roi est beaucoup trop
faible
[Musique]
donnons-leur venir on lit que le fou son
roi maintenant est très très faible
un petit échec quelques petits échecs
bien bien senti là et ça devrait être
bon quarante cinq secondes il nous reste
ça va
mv en tête des candidats ouais ça lui à
ce kit qui nous a rejoint donc c'est le
skip d'elle en tête des candidats à
égalité live à égalité à une épaule
match mais c'était vraiment l'aps il y
avait une partie a gagné c'était
celle-là est vraiment ok alors très bien
donc ici on va jouer cinq donc là l'idée
c'est de commencer à pouvoir créer des
menaces ici et aussi de pouvoir pourquoi
pas pousser jusque jusqu'à 4 1 c'est une
possibilité
alors ok maintenant sans doute tout
simplement prise
et puis adam prend la dame prend l'air
très bien puisque sa menace aussi damage
4 et qu il ya un fou ici ça commence à
sentir un peu là c'est bizarre d'un
échec
alors faut des quatre échecs ou là en
seconde
donc normalement il n'ya plus 3 quand
même un échec échec échec c'est de
gagner adam je crois ça doit gagner la
dame
ce qui a fait trois ans maintenant la
dame est perdu le roi est obligé de s'en
aller voilà échec semaine la tour aussi
voilà
et oui le roi était trop faible donc ça
a marché on a affaibli le roi et blanc
ont cru dans leur pio passé centrale pas
longtemps le roi était trop faible
ça a craqué salut à régis bienne soucis
qui nous a rejoint ça lui allait donc on
joue face à florian en 333 on va jouer 4
c 5
qu'est ce qu'on a dit que jouer sur ces
cinq qu'ils ont jouées b3 pour éviter on
veut éviter l'ambition c'est mieux
d'éviter les grandes variantes au final
tout cas pour moi je préfère 21 peu
pointu où il faut vraiment être très
précis et on risque de tomber contre des
adversaires qui connaissent très bien
passé d'ouverture très peu analysé ça
parce que ça donne pas un avantage
énorme aux blancs voire pas davantage du
tout mais c'est pas c'est pas très grave
koubi de déjouer kaliev 6 très bien lors
des trois cas les c3 c3 c'est bien à ça
c'est intéressant ça me permet de jouer
ça permet de vous caler des scènes comme
mon nom ça en a tout l'air ok là on peut
jouer kf3 et maintenant par contre il
doit falloir prendre un f6 hockey alors
maintenant ou m notre fou parce que si
on le met là le problème c'est qu'il a
du mal à reculer en kabylie t'attaquer
donc il faut plutôt le maître en te le
mettre en haut de mes 6 juin 2
j'ai pas trop le choix en fait j'ai
l'impression que si je joue j'ai trois
pour 8 des trois et ça y est je suis je
suis pas ok j'ai pas le temps et je vais
me faire défoncer au centre je vous
poussez 4 non je suis obligé de la photo
ces faibles mais je me sens pas très
bien placé se fout ici mais je suis
obligé de jouer comme ça si je vous
rockets de manière sécurisée et je
préfère rockets de manière sécurisée ça
me ça me sécurise justement et 6 1 ok
allez maintenant donc petit rock c'est
un bon coup c'est un bon coup et cinq
bombes
attention je prenne d'abord ici il y
aurait pu peut-être prendre quatre noms
n'étaient pas très bon hockey et
maintenant il doit falloir prendre ici
et j'ai pas on ne peut pas dire j'ai une
très bonne position
page pas très très bien ici je suis pas
mal mais je suis pas bien
alors d'être trop un tout simplement
obligé de jouer très très passif droit
où tour à un sas est toujours
l'éternelle question qu'elle tournait
autour des mêmes plutôt non ouais on va
mettre tout re 1 et peut-être fou et feu
derrière peut-être aussi clé le fou je
sais pas je ne sais pas trop où l'un
mais je trouve ma position pas très
bonne heure alors pour s' est ok trop
c'est trop cette recette alors sans
doute h3
h3 parce que j'ai pas envie de jouer
tout est fin et me prendre un fou g4
c'est pas parce que j'ai pas omettre le
cavalier prix alors moi j'ai une classe
pour le cavalier et puis j'ai des fois
je peut menacer des g4 et là est-ce que
j'ai peur des changes et je sais pas
trop sans doute je ne peu peur mais donc
j'ai tout de suite de toute façon alors
qu'est ce qu'on va faire ici du coup
enfin ce que vous ces trois peut-être
c'est faiblard sam affaiblissent 1 avec
le fouquet la même pas trop oui j'arrive
à placer mes pièces assez de problèmes
sont mal placés fafa me paraît pas pour
ce qui est prise prise prix d'aia dame b
2 après qui me le piquer un pion ça que
j'ai envie de faire ces 3
allez je fais ces trois jeux pas hyper
convaincu mais je vois que ça tout de
suite
ok alors maintenant fouet fin tout
reprendre tout reprendra me prend la fin
il ya des trois non on n'est pas des
trois coups allez on fait ça et là
peut-être après je vais aussi clément
fond de g2 sera mue en g2 est ce que là
il quand même ils butent sur des trois
pas terrible il n'a pas de maître sur
une diagonale quand même où ils peuvent
venir vers le centre ça sera sans doute
un peu mieux ici on aime peu resserré
bon nero serré alors mr pour le coup
j'aurais laissé la tour ce serait fun
pour être en phase de la dame par
convention mais la position est très
complexe à poulies sur les complexes
well as well alors ça fou prend h3c le
coup pas prévu qu est un bon coup
puisque si je prends bien sûr il ya
dimpre en scène permettant enfin c'est
embêtant
disons que je perds un pion quoi alors
je peux jouer des quatre ici pas du tout
pensé à ça allez on va on va échanger un
peu pour alléger parce qu'il est il est
quand même doublé sur la colonne eux
c'est un peu pénible
voilà surtout à accélérer un tout petit
peu la cadence de jeu aussi on a perdu
un pion mais c'est pas c'est pas le plus
haut le plus grave à perdre c'est un
pion un pion h
pas la fin du monde voilà ok bon on va
échanger les tours c'est déjà ça de pris
ok maintenant peut-être g3 foulée 2
allez je vais trois fous j'ai deux sans
doute
les noirs sont mieux et il en reste
quand même à trouver comment améliorer
leur position peut-être sur alors ce cas
les dessins qui attaque un peu jeté
ajouté quatre ans l'un des quatre qui
m'a l'air bien ça me plaît bien
ça nous plaît bien pris ce prise nord
sont mieux une 18 contre 2,33 m 6 2 6 2
6 2 6 ouais dame si ce salaire bien phu
c4 a l'air pas mal aussi un petit plonge
il y avait il y avait peut-être non
c'est bien ça c'est bizarre ça 3 haye
adam échec mais ce n'est pas prévu
la dame échec
ouais mais cheikh donc ok là est-ce que
je monte ou pas ouais je vais pas
laisser aller j'essaie d'éviter les
changes des pièces
alors qu'avaient laissé de calais c'est
de ces moments de jouer g4 sans doute
juste à temps ou pas il prend quand même
d'accord on est vraiment mal là on est
vraiment très mal
ouais faut bien c'est presque trop bien
joué ça hein c'est bizarre allez à 3 on
est très très mal ici 3
des 5 tout à fait logique bon il faut
les trois annoncé à perdant sa quille à
calais c'est un ouais allez je sais pas
la peine d'insister je lui fais
confiance pour la terminer on était trop
serré et on a fait un vrai four h3 et
c'était trop simple après jouer pour lui
il n'ya pas compliquer la vie s'y passe
est allé battre calais 3 allez on va
jouer avec vous ces quatre on va jouer
notre moi je veux lutter trois sets
petit rock c3
salut à montory tories ouais maxime a
battu le effectivement maxime a gagné
ici toi quel est des deux fauves et
celles qui l'idée c'est de paris changé
sous et c'est pour ça que le coup c'est
3 permet au fou d'aller se cacher en c2
je vais pas les changer ce fou contre le
cavalier là bas allez h3 ici
alors surtout pour un f3 peut-être d'en
prendre
s'il fait pas voilà là ça va me
permettre de jouer qu alger 3 avec
gaines de teint sans doute sur le fond
ça m'étonnerait qu'ils laissent se fout
se laisser prendre
voilà hélas le fuet trump est obligé
d'aller en justice voilà alors
maintenant il suffit pas de l'or sans
doute cavailles h4 alors l'idée de 44
c'est pas de prendre ici l'idée c'est
d'aller sur la la case kasparov la la
casse qui vaut un pion kazan f5
kasparov qui dit mettez-moi donnez moi
un cavalier avec 5 et je considère que
ça - pions jeu pourra donner un pion
pour m 9 5 est en mission et qui aurait
laissé la torsion refn pour tout à
l'heure en partie pour être en phase de
la dame
par convention mais la position est
complexe mais dans la position qui est
pas facile bon c'est pas grave façon là
on joue vraiment détendue et s'est
tourné en ligne devront laisser de bien
jouer mais on essaye des trucs aussi
bons dans ce qu'ils pensent plaindre des
fois ça marche des fois ça marche pas
c'est ça qui est bien avec le blitz
aussi succès ça permet de tenter des
trucs tout en n'étant pas trop affecté
par le résultat
si beaucoup de parties à jouer donc on a
perdu hop on enchaîne une autre et tout
va bien
en tout cas ça fait réfléchir et ça ça
si bien ça c'est bien pour nous alors
celui là oui celui là c'est bien
j'attaque la fossette
alors est-ce qu'on peut jouer h 4 h 5
600 dottori allez on y va on est bien
placé pour puisque nos fous lorsque la
l1 peut bloquer bien sûr pour l'instant
mais à tout moment des cats pourrait le
débloquer 6 6 6 e 4 venait à devoir
bouger en cas de descente par exemple
être comme ça si les noirs jouer des
scènes qu cela pourrait se réveiller
pour être très dangereux et celui là est
très bien par contre aussi pour attaquer
les cases noires
par contre pour aveugles le fait quand
même un bijou d'accord ok je fais quand
même
il n'a [ __ ] 5 c1
j'ai montré les cases et j'ai cliqué là
ce que je lui dise qu'il accepte le
retour non elle n'est pas de retour
possible
ouais j'ai fait un slip la mort ce clip
je donne une pièce net âgées clic et en
montrant la case bon tant pis mauvaise
manip et j'insiste pas parce que ou
cadence trop molle pour pour essayer
faire mieux à quel dommage de cette
partie il était bien engagée la tempo
lent les courbes du mal à s'enchaîner
c'est un peu lent il ya mille 180 ses
joueurs un peu comme la semaine dernière
donc on appelle ce hammam seul slip on
glisse mansouri ah ouais on a glissé et
on a cliqué sur la mauvaise case ferme
j'ai pas fait attention tant pis aller
ces 5
et on va pour jouer avec b3 on va
essayer de faire plus attention je vais
que senki 6 2 ces trois
ces quatre peut-être clément face à une
prétention parce qu'il peut se passer
des trucs ici
alors est-ce qu'il ya pas d j'ai trop
envie d'aller prendre je prends je
calcule pas je prends échec trombi
beaucoup trop envie d'aller prendre
parce que c'est un peu thématique de
faire ce type d'attaqué bon là j'ai
envie j'ai juste envie de le faire alors
ok peut-être six pour voir leur menace
déjà une fourchette ici dam tour sur
calais ou 5
il ya vous prend
voilà donc qui craque un peu senti
obligé de rendre la pièce
ok il a rendu la pièce alors ici qu'est
ce qu'on fait je peux prendre angers7
je veux jouer dame g4 aussi 2004 c'est
l'heure pas mal j'aime bien dame g4 faut
que je fasse attention quand même comme
g4 est bien mais ouais ça leur bien
damas de et moins de bien j'aime
pression parce que tu es valeo 5
quoique adam hansen qui peut-être pas
mal damages 5 à bac 5 c'est pas mal g6
et damages trois dames h5 g6 et forcé
alors l'idée vous avez la voir dommage 3
alors est ce que je fais damage 3 je
peux aussi faire dame d'un mode ou tout
simplement
dans le 2e set peut-être mieux c'est
peut-être plus s'ajoute un g4 est pas
mal aussi
lab21 les dames deux c'est plus sage or
l'intérêt d'avoir fait ça c'est qu'ils
aient attaqué qui peut pas faire ce
qu'il veut maintenant d'invoquer on a
récupéré la pièce hockey que les dessins
qu'elle ait des simples et des scènes
clés des 5
c'est dommage que j'ai plus le damage
center parce que du coup ce que valent
ils ont ignoré morfler mais alors
peut-être peut-être cavaliers c3 tout
simplement des quatre est pas mal aussi
non cavalli ce ici pour le mettre en c4
mais après il ya pas beaucoup de cases
calais c3 est peut-être bien tout
simplement une c3 avec citron fasse
attention à lui il est défendu que par
la dame alors là on peut faire pions
prendre de manière à libérer les tours
ou alors fou prend mais ça libère pas
les tours on vous prend l'air mieux
quand même c'est un pêche les noirs de
bouger surtout le fou voilà il faut pas
beaucoup de cases voilà il aime pas
obligé d'aller là maintenant qu'est ce
qu'on va faire
alors j'ai presque envie de faire pour d
un taureau 20 ou six tours à un aussi
pour jouer ensuite f4 f5 peut-être tu
m'as l'air bien aussi je réfléchis à
voir s'il ya pas mieux
tu aurais fait un tour au 1 si je fais
tout re s ça en d4 peut-être un peu
moins fort et si je t'aurais feu je
pourrais peut-être plus poussées 4 fcm
f4 f5 qu'est-ce que ça mène parce
qu'après prise pour prendre il ya aussi
les chèques l'un c'est vrai oui donc s4i
peut-être pas mal quand même
allez-vous 4 tout de suite skf 5a peut
avoir de l'intérêt en cas de prise et ça
libère en échec ici aussi il faut pas
oublier alors ouais même si sur l'échec
à tour j'ai six cas l'air de tenir à peu
près 1
on va d'abord protéger le cavalier une
fois de plus le droit qui peut pas
bouger c'est l'horreur un pour les noirs
ici ça ah ça c'est intéressant parce
qu'il veut bloquer mon mail arrière en
iran ce pion encore plus arriérées sans
doute ici il veut bloquer mon fou et moi
j'ai pas envie qu'ils ne bloquent m'en
fous je peux jouer des quatre pour ce
compte pour contrer sa des quatre armes
lourdes et 4 allée des 4 as l'air bien
des cas ça me plaît
oula ça permet de prendre
alors après si je prends un il va jouer
des 4 ouais ok alors j'ai perdu mon beau
cavalier là j'aurais pas dû j'aurais
peut-être pas dû aller on va prendre
quand même
à
ça c'est bizarre qu'il peut jouer des 4
4 pour protéger fallait qu'ils jouent
des 4 certainement mais j'aurais
peut-être coup et je sais pas de même 5
km 5 km 5 2 512 mb 5 clouage oui alors
ça ça permet de prendre le plan b si ce
nom
attention va peut-être réfléchir un peu
il ya aussi tour un ton des cinq est
comme un bail
attention m'attaque de où j'ai pas vu ça
je vais le voir en sept tours 2-1 tours
2 histoire de protéger ces deux là je
n'ai pas vu qu'il attaquait aussi ici le
world s'est pas de raison de lui lâcher
des choses faciles et l'a peut-être fou
b2b seconde rats c'est une pression que
le serveur élan quoi c'est lent lent
lent c'est roland gsm gsm g5 à les tours
l2 qu'est ce que tu fais mon coco
il faut jouer un peu vite parce qu'il me
reste que 19 secondes mais il ya plus 3
à l'est d'al oula leucate à les prises
dames 1 tav 3 pouces assez ça me paraît
dangereux ça me prendre des 5
donc prendre pour prendre qui check
ouais ouais et là il faut peut-être joué
d'un mètre 5 échecs bouge on bouge ils
essaient me faire tomber mais y'a plus 3
donc le coup de faire tomber ça marche
plus avec +3 si on vous si on joue
correctement alors ici b5 encore aller
h3 pour éviter les maths du couloir
tendu la peau un fauve et si j'avais
tout efois 3 les x 3 on commence à
attaquer le pion cette dame prend b6
cavalier est attaqué aussi
ouais ouais échec ah non ça marche pas
vers la femme hockey à la je pensais
faire un échec ici mais papa de la dame
bien sûr 3 quel dommage
voilà les blues sont techniquement
gagnant parce que le roi est trop faible
et bon il reste du temps encore il ya
trois secondes mais c'est un peu lent
sas a du mal à répondre comme ça prend
du temps a joué et j'ai l'impression que
ça bouffe les presque les trois secondes
à chaque fois bon alors là bon c'est sûr
que si je fais d'un rêve 2 c'est sûr que
ça peut pas ça peut pas marcher
allez tant pis on est dans une semaine
où on perd beaucoup de parties d'affilée
a perdu hier pas mal d'affilée ça fait
trois d'affilée compères la foire se
réveiller un peu quand même mais bon
c'est là c'est dommage quand meme sénat
c'est dommage
était elle était terminée quoi il
n'avait plus qu'à la et plus qu'à la
finir à l'achat comme on dit ali
jean-jacques que louison elle joue avec
les normes donc b3 très bien moi je vais
qu'alexis 5 vous et ça ne peut pas être
mauvais
il a avalé g4 pose déjà des problèmes au
noir ce qu'il ya le pion à f2 ici il y
avait les preuves attaque la dame où la
bombe à prendre la dame tout simplement
ce que je tente damage quatre matches
quatre cavaliers des trois échecs re
deux dames échec one on va prendre la
dame allait prendre la dame
après on va jouer avec peut-être faut
ouvrir les lignes ici donc on va jouer
ou des quatre sans doute
ah ça perd encore une pièce
ces quatre on va rauque et puis ensuite
on moi je vous sais 6 des cinq en
intérêt à ouvrir au maximum le jeu avec
quand on a du matériel en plus donc des
cinq ça va ouvrir les lignes au maximum
plus ça permet de faire flouer cheikh
ici je fais d'abord faux échec
peut-être ici damev 6 1 ouais c'est bien
d'un v6
un proche du roi noir durable en
parement en pause ou un blanc voilà et
ça il ya dame f3 qui attaquent à la fois
le cavalier et la tour
jérémy l'otan comme ce que vous gagnez
ouais bah oui il faut gérer au mieux le
temps on est d'accord on est d'accord
avec ça fo prend h 2 mais le servir
honnêtement a du mal à vraiment répondre
c'est vraiment aller dans prend échec et
mat
ok allez on va essayer d'enchaîner le
salon alors répondre peu mal aussi
voilà c'est vrai depuis hier mais je
crois c'est vrai quand les noms de
joueurs est important la 1215 et se
croit aussi que le nombre de joueurs sur
litière est en train d'exploser c'est à
dire qu on approche les cent mille
joueurs connectés en même temps alors je
crois qu'ils sont pas tous justement ils
sont répartis sur plusieurs serveurs je
crois mais tu pas comme un petit bout
géré ça mais je sais que l'équipe de
leeds qui a mené partie bull duplessiste
en train aussi de faire des
améliorations en termes de temps de
réponse
ça fait quelques petites amélia et loupé
un math qu'elles notent
je vais te faire matelas non il y avait
un math avant peut-être pas vu possible
je sais pas alors allez on va essayer de
se rattraper un peu allégés 6 pouces et
allez petit rock on est sur une un
accord on est sur une saint mich
alors qu'on va traiter ça je peux la
traiter avec eux ces six des cinq
manière peu habituelle
ça peut ça peut gêner l'adversaire
ah ça c'est un peu étonnant
voici peut-être alors prise prise hu
dans le prix dans le cas de prise non
elle n'est pas michael 6,6 et bien prise
en main quatre reprises se trouvera pas
un six ateliers pareil avec les g4 qui
était bien ben ça j'aurais pu faire
prises des 5 juste avant prise prise que
les quatre ça suffit pas comment on va
faire ainsi
tris prise quand j'ai quatre l'échec
un epr échec
ok donc je pense qu'il va falloir
essayer de jouer sur cette case
est ce que si je prends faut éviter de
se prendre un dessin contre le fou donc
peut-être il faut c'est de mettre le
foulard
ok donc là cavalier ok alors on va
prendre ça nous prend ici tant pis il
prend pas ces quatre ils auraient dû
prendre sans doute un os 6
intermédiaires les blancs un forçat
entre apparent a encore une fois j'avais
calligé 4 aux mains ce qu'elle jk
c'était mieux que ce que je vais le
faire mais bon tant pis même s'ils
prenaient derrière il y avait des quatre
qui sautait les plaines menace mais bon
tant pis c'est comme ça
ok alors peut-être g4 quand même ouais
kg 4 c'est bien mouais
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait ici
mais attention pas faire de bêtises
est-ce que je peux prendre cinq prises
prises et ça a pas l'air
donc on va prendre ce fou qui est
important
puis ici c'est pas mal ce que ça va me
permettre de sauter sans doute sur la
case c4 alors ce qui a même pas mieux
ici c'est quand c'est quand même très
tentant allez on le fait parce que
maintenant il faut qu'ils défendent
beaucoup de choses
il s'en sort pile poil un cavalier
prendre b2 les prends ça marche
calais prend b2 c'est pas mal s'y prend
du cavalier hyper lecavalier et s'y
prendre de la dame
iliad homme prend l'échec et que les
deux fous prend ça à l'air d'être un peu
suffisant
quoique non et non ça marche à les cayes
premier de valeur de marché alors trouvé
cinq plus hauts f8 la f3 et mat
j'aime pas jouer des positions fermes et
comme sur la liste indienne oui mais
alors ces dépositions qui sont ceux
d'eau fermé puisque en fait elles
peuvent éclater à tout moment
c'est à dire qu'on fait la pression
augmente jusqu'à l'éclatement en quoi
c'est au contraire c'est pas soyons il
faut savoir jouer un peu des positions
fermes et on à défendre parce que
souvent on n'a pas le choix on fait tout
simplement
waouh ça c'est curieux quand même bon on
va revenir à temps il faut voir s'il va
mieux tout tout tout eu ouais allez on
va accélérer un peu que ces quatre aussi
surtout et c'est 2 voilà de tenir la
distance au temps et donc messi sans
doute c'est pas sûr on prend fou prend
faut trois à jouer ça
ok donc là j'ai envie de tenter commencé
à tenter quelques trucs j'ai oublié faut
trois ans mais je suis pas sûr non c'est
pas trés trés bon le coin
donc il faut jouer autre chose c'est pas
facile comme une position quand même des
tripes 5
c'est une prise prix c'est un peu un peu
risqué voire même totalement risquer ta
main à l'équipe dames 17 à l'air
tranquille
en première analyse du 28/01 c'est fou
le temps incroyable ok maintenant
maintenant peut-être fausse six kits
contre menace les contre-feux peut-être
hipsheim maintenant c'est d'éclater le
position blanche c'est déstabiliser ce
cavalier saran celui-là faible et le
pion central est tout seul bon il peut
s'avérer fort c'est un risque
et ouais et puis surtout il ya une
fourchette d'accord ok une fourchette
c'est vrai que c'est gênant que bonifier
2003 c'est un peu compliqué encore quand
il peut rendre de la qualité peut-être
position est très complexe ici c'est
très compliqué ouais ça c'est possible
il aya cavalli est d'abord peut-être
touré suit toujours les coûts
intermédiaires aux échecs très important
où va la dame
ouah ça c'est énorme ça doit être
par contre ça n'a pas marché simplement
dame je fais 4 et aux menaces mat
et on attaque aussi le cavalier 4 mais
je peux toujours pas prendre ici c'est
ce qu'avait dit attaquer s'il fait tout
reprend il ya vous prend et en cas de
toux reprend il va ya voir matt ici et
puis là le problème aussi c'est que la
tour va attaquer f1 donc ça se complique
quand même pour les blancs 55 secondes
contre 2,07
c'est très compliqué l'un à poussan et
très complexe que je calcule même pas
ici a tellement c'est compliqué vous
prend il ya d'un cran et abandon direct
ok allez commencer à marquer un peu des
points pas facile les joueurs sont forts
il ya beaucoup de joueurs ils sont fort
ans
salut à steve steve qui nous a rejoint
un salut steve bonsoir donc voilà pour
ce direct sur sur des bonal tv n'oubliez
pas de laisser un commentaire dans la
description si ça vous a plu
si vous avez des remarques ou des envies
de direct
j'ai laissé faire aux 4,7 fois alors je
trouve à roque et joue avec ses six
baies 5 c6 est souvent bien parce que ça
empêche voilà ok donc on fait ces six ça
empêche les câbles et b5 et ça a brassé
envisage aussi de faire des baies 5 à 3
4 à 4 et ambigu je crois parce que ça
affaiblit cette case et donc ça permet
de faire des trucs tendance apparue
peut-être de 12,5 rapide non je vais
profiter de ce coup qui est pas un coup
hyper rapide de développement pour
essayer de l'embêter au centre le plus
vite possible avec eux 5g pas si c'est
la meilleure réponse du tout j'en sais
rien du tout évidemment les blancs pour
y prendre
ici on a l'impression qu'ils pourraient
prendre une plus en ses mains c'est que
c'est compliqué parce qu'après il ya
cabaye prend 1,4 avec le fou qui peut
récupérer le cavalier au centre et
beaucoup d'eau
il devient très très fort ce fonds
il peut changer les dames mais ça ça
résout pas le ça résout pas la faire ok
ça c'est possible
ces quatre jeux pas sûr que ça ça mène à
grand chose
il faut être prudent toutefois peut-être
joué trop vite tout simplement pour
l'instant l'idée c'est de consolider
peut-être un peu fou et 6,6 fait
cavalier g5 ont fait un cours commun non
pourra pas faire un mince pape a fait un
retour essuie-tout toro set puisqu'il ya
poussé 5
ouais bon donc je vous faut si ce temps
pire c'est quand même pas besoin j'ai
pas envie de faire fossile alors un
taureau sept fous ces cinq tours 17
wes à la détrempe pièce est un piège
classique du truc là tant pis aller il
faut aussi semble un peu un peu obligé
c'est pas beau hein c'est pas ça qu'il
aurait fallu faire mais tant pis bon des
fois les plans doubler ici sont bien
parce qu'ils contrôlent beaucoup de
cases et empêche beaucoup de choses ok
et c'est sans doute ici et 17 pour
libérer cette tour un an peut-être joué
au fc est pas tout de suite
alors peut-être qu'on va jouer fouet
suite d'un contrôle des cases notamment
la classe des six
ça permet éventuellement de s'échanger
contre ce fou peut-être
les plantes peuvent aussi dans ce type
de position je le sais pour les jouets
des fois et bien des fois s'épuise à
essayer de trouver un avantage et perdre
énormément de temps et à la fin c'est
psychologiquement dur de se retrouver
après d'imposition qui qui commence à
tourner à gaia et l'égalité alors qu'on
pensait avant l' avantage donc fini par
faire des bêtises
c'est parfois bien parties rapides c'est
parfois bien de défendre en fait parce
que ça ça prend moins de temps que
d'attaquer alors fou
ces cinq allées pour propose les changes
est bon on échange
allez donc maintenant alors qu'avaient
laissé cinq noms peut-être cavaliers
suite tout simplement
voilà c'est très très solide ici les
blancs et les noirs aucun avantage on
peut pas dire qu'on est mieux même
je suis pas sûr que les blancs ici est
un avantage quelconque même s'il y avait
les mêmes si les prix ont doublé
facile avantage il est pas facile à
transformer en tout cas
les quatre sans doute une bonne idée si
l'attaqué à al elam on va centraliser
maintenant un peu euros 1,7
ici ça va ça va libérer un peu nos
cavaliers de la défense notamment de 6
peut-être de 17 aussi parce que déjà un
roi qui protège ont peut-être éliminer
une perte de tours ça simplifiera aussi
si on a le roi 7 on peut éliminer ou une
paire de tours partons des 8 es bon ma
foi alors si c'est intéressant
en fait recette on continue notre plan
de tranquille en jouant rapidement
ok maintenant cavalier à 4 qu'il ya 4
pourquoi pas il veut mettre le cavalier
en csn peut-être eh bien nous on va
mettre un cavalier de 17 ans mais celui
là on joue très très défensif c'est ça
permet de prendre non ouais et on va
échanger une paire de tours attention
parce que ses pions commence à être sont
très faibles sais pas qui commence
ils sont très faibles
werritty noirs les blancs way sont un
peu obligé de rendre le doublement des
pions alors ici d'abord j'ai lu une
paire de tours ça c'est sûr ça c'est
fait après ce que je prends ici ou
est-ce que je joue quel et 17 ou est-ce
que je joue au roi m6 si ça peut être
pas mal aussi
j'ai envie de prendre je prends
il joue aussi ce jeu me pro ce même pas
pour les prendre ça parce qu'ici il joue
droit là ah oui mais ça j'ai pas ça j'ai
participé par contre mais où que jouer
autour des 8 allée de 38 contre 1,36
prise prises et quand il re 5 jours
montrent il pourra pas empêcher que l
aider cet échec
il va monter le roi c'est sûr je le sens
non oui non peut-être et j'ai
l'impression que la finale mais
favorable mais c'est lui maintenant qu'à
des pions doublé way suis là en plus on
peut éloigner c'est pas grave il peut
jouer peut-être à 6 mais voilà les
recettes quand même et là ça se passe
assez je pense pas que ce soit très bon
coup que quoi que quoi que je joue à 6
peut-être ici quand même hein je joue à
six alors il check
non
échec et ça y est je viens un pion et
petit à petit ma finale être se
transformer en finale gagnante
je vais peut-être ce que je joue ça
ouais ouais ouais je suis pas pressé je
fixe sur cases noires et ça devrait être
bon ça ça va tomber et ça aussi ça
devrait tomber parce que il est sûre il
n'est pas défendable par le fou et donc
ça devrait gagner ça allait maintenant
doré pouvant jouer vite servites assez
fou hein
c'est un peu ce qui s'est passé à peu
près ce que j'avais prévu j'ai
simplement joué passivement défensif les
blancs se sont emballés et ils
s'écrasent un petit peu contre le mur
des des noirs avec l'expérience on sait
qu'en fait ces positions là sont très
très dur à gagner en fait les pions
double au centre c'est pas toujours
c'est pas toujours une faiblesse c'est
clair je réagisse bien une de mes
défenses préférées non ça c'était tout à
l'heure pour la liste indienne alors
est-ce que 21 secondes mais bon on
aurait marqué là
alors est-ce que allez on devrait
marquer à moins qu'on fasse encore mouse
asleep eu un truc un truc pas beau alors
comment on va attaquer ça il faudrait
mettre le cas vaillance et six ont déjà
on va monter l'euro à ça c'est sûr
ensuite on va jouer que les 17 c sur
aussi là le roi peut passer peut-être on
va peut-être passer le roi et non on va
jouer cavalier là et celui-là il va
tomber parce que le fou ne peut pas on
ne peut pas il ya le roi qu'est la haye
le roi est allée du mauvais côté
mais tous tombent c'est sa tombe comment
le comme des fruits mûrs
merci à mon stack victoire yes et donc
on marque notre le premier quatre points
eh bien il était temps 1
il était temps voilà c'est qu'on
enseigne 3 sur deux ans peut pas c'est
pauvre a pas faire beaucoup de blitz
parce que ça dure au moins ça dure dix
minutes cette partie
voilà dix tous partis pas plus quoi
aller premier doit être très très loin
ils sont à combien les premiers sont
déjà 46 voix on préfère donc allée des
quatre cavaliers sis à ben on va
peut-être toile et on va peut-être
offert le même du coup ouais on va faire
il faut g7 alors 6 ouah ça c'est gonflé
[Musique]
direct des cinq têtes auraient pu jouer
juste avant enfin
pour cent des 305 pour empêcher g4
essaie de garder ce fou là alors
maintenant peut-être à 6 à 6 ok ok ça
sente on échange et aux joutes a blessé
six 6 i way sa valeur bien sa manière à
peu près correct à peu pris
17 ça veut pas dire que je vais faire le
grand rouquin ça veut dire que je me
madam 1,17 c'est tout je préfère le
préciser
alors celles prises bruges pas peut-être
petit robe de coûts est-ce que je prends
à vendin parce que je prends non
peut-être aussi peut-être 6 solide et
3,53 contre 4,45
ça va pour l'instant kidwai autant
toujours ok donc ça ça m'oblige à
repartir je vais sans doute passées par
sept
ok là même temps peut-être le grand
entre maintenant par contre mais c'est
pas sûr parce qu'il y avait il ya 4 qui
m'embête quand même avec le cavalier qui
viendraient ici
alors peut-être beesan peut-être cavale
et b4 avant un coup comme il ya quatre
cavaliers 4 est d'accord allez on fait
un grand bien
je passe sur soi très bon mais aussi
fuite
tous les cas pas le cas on va prend
crise prises ok maintenant ce qu'il vous
faut
non
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire ici
j'aurais peut-être que ça tout simple
alors ma tach potentiellement ce pion 5
est possible quatre prix je prends ces
dangereux quand même ça mieux face à la
tour c'est pas terrible terrible je vais
pas embouteiller là en fait on va
défendre
peut-être mon cavalier pourrait passer
par là un hockey 6 ça c'est embêtant
c'est très embêtant
ouais tout ici on vous très passif
encore une fois j'ai pas trop le choix
en fait pas trop le choix
je peux viser la galette 5 alors prise
prise n'a pas fait le bon choix en fait
ils pouvaient jouer à sept tours g7 y
avait foule ce 6 et gt1 j'étais quand
même assez un assez embêter voire même
totalement bt alors on va mettre le
petit lecavalier en angers 6
essayer de monter quelque chose allait
le dam de 0,9 contre 3,50 pas terrible
ce que j'ai fait ma position est pas je
n'aime pas beaucoup mais bon faut savoir
tenir ce type de trucs être patient ça
compte aussi
ouais ouais donc les rois ici l'idée ça
peut être de saper ces cinq points
d'écart entre de manière à ce que ce fou
bougeait ok ça c'est intéressant mais je
peux jouer c'est simple tout de suite
voilà
ça ça peut libérer mon fou mon fois de
suite qui pour l'instant est quand même
un peu un peu coincé tue pas trop
inquiet pour l'instant par ses pions là
parce qu'ils sont bien bloqué sur tout
le plancher 5 par rapport à geci ce
qu'avait le sait tous que j'évite et
celui-là il est bloqué voilà mes gars
ben voilà il peut faire ça mais il
n'aura pas très loin alors touché six
cavaliers f4 séparables france c'est pas
grave qu'elles f4 ça m'est égal je
prends vraiment je donne la qualité ça
m'est égal je te donne la qualité sont
les pièces sont beaucoup mieux on donne
à la qualité et je risque à voir si ça
ça ça disparaît ce qui est plus que
probable maintenant ça va me donner une
marée de pions ici pour quand ça va
avancer ça donc là les blancs fine sans
doute une mauvaise estimation
positionnelle ici de ce qui se passe
ça reste ça risque d'être assez dur pour
les blancs maintenant parce que ça c'est
quand ils ont bloqué par contre mes
pions là une fois que celui-là le pion
central aura sauté
ouille ouille ouille ouille ça va ça va
être très très très très puissant et
pour les arrêter faudra au moins de
donner une pièce minimum qu'elle les
prend en attaque la dame à bessat sais
pas j'ai pas fait attention
aïe et oui mais c'est vrai qu'il me
cloue pas du tout fait attention ça fait
rien allez on sort c'est pas voir ça
change pas grand chose
heureusement j'ai vu dernier moment il
m'a cloué rage et du mal avec sa vie
clouage je les vois pas arriver toujours
il va sans doute reprendre le cavalier
se fout d'eux vaudra largement une tour
1 parce qu'il est très très puissant
ouais ça c'est dangereux
il faut prendre de toute façon pas trop
le choix est maintenant à il faut faire
gaffe ici peut-être oui je peux tu étais
obligé de donner le fou dames et c'est
peut-être ce qui veut jouer il veut
jouer tour j'ai vite bon fin juin 2007
en cas tout jute échanges qu'on est
temps que ce fou contrôle ça bon jeu
peut toujours donner le fou
éventuellement est toujours beaucoup de
pions en mai c'est vrai que moi j'ai pas
j'ai pas fait attention à son cou la 2
j'aurais pu sans doute le contrer avant
de prendre 5
je trouve été trop confiants là j'étais
un peu trop confiant
oui
donc là on retourne ici et sa pendule
est en train de descendre dramatiquement
il faut sortir le roi de la caisse
au prix d'un prend la mef 6 3 2 et
random attention aussi parce que là il
ya une batterie là qui pourrait on est
d'accord ok ça c'est pas mal on va faire
ils seront ici sans moteur
allez
échec dès 6h obligé en fait d'un v6 ah
oui à wigan vue très bien vu très très
bien vu
il peut faire échec après on bouge et
peut faire damer fuite à elles font
pousser
alors eh ouais ouais c'est bien vu allez
j'arrête c'est bon donc si je reviens
avant je me suis fait déborder ici
jusque là ça allait je pense
voilà si j'ai pris trop vite sur ça j'ai
pas du tout pensé au cloud alger
vraiment pas pensé à ça et donc
peut-être ici je peux faire f4 je joue
f4 donc du coup y'a pas de ya pas de
fous là et ceux qui on va tomber le coup
d'après par exemple par fou prends et je
pense que je contrôle ses pions et je
dois pouvoir avancer et c'est vrai que
le clouage
peut-être le cavalier qu'il faut que je
garde ici je suis pas ok bon bijoux et
un pour lui mais but s'est accroché et
il a bien il a bien terminé
saluée pilote mmg salut allez on va
jouer face à coup comme aller au 4 on va
jouer des quatre on va prendre les 3 et
le 27.4 le troisième
que des deux
tu commences à viser un peu loquace 2,5
qui est quand même un petit peu la casse
vers laquelle les pions avance enfin les
piaules la caisse dans laquelle les
pions regard d'un pardon alors donc là
faut pas jouer adams et deux à cause de
câbles et b4 et iai un clouage du pion
ici à cause de la tour par contre d'âme
des uns est sans doute jouable ici
l'idée c'est des clous et ce cavalier un
peu
alors ici kfk tiens on va prendre ce
reprendre souffle maintenant joue
cavalier f3 et on a un bon contrôle de
la caisse de cinq crises prise 400v cinq
à quatre ça permet d'affaiblir ça c'est
un coût qui me semble un peu prématuré
on peut oser d'un v6 pas mal simple
allez prise prise annonce un bon coup
finalement c'est pas si ni primature et
news et c'est beaucoup
faut prendre puis on prend tout reprend
2,6 g 6 qui était dans l'air aussi que
le 5 est pas mal aussi jeu 4 quel point
faut prendre pions prendre ne prend pas
ce que ça marche comme on va continuer
ici
5 c'est pas un nom ça me plaît pas je
vais prendre tout simplement et on prend
que les 17 que les vannes tombent elles
15 ans et 5 presque envie d'aller
prendre un g6 j'ai envie de faire ça ça
me tente pas ce que ça affaiblit aussi
le pion aux 6 bon allez on y va on va
voir ce que ça donne
[Musique]
ça récupère au moins deux pions plus
semble-t-il ou très bonne position
bon donc on va voir ça à l'air pas mal
quand même ça leur prometteur sepa sepa
gagnant ce genre de sacrifices mais
c'est quand même cette fille ce qui
permet d'envisager une attaque sympa on
peut faire tout prendre 6 tout de suite
parce que là il reste sans doute tours 8
il ya aussi cavale et gsm tout de suite
c'est pas mal c'est pas sûr parce
qu'après il ferait cavalier ou quatre
qui me bloque donc il faut il faut
peut-être prendre ici pour éviter que
cavaliers aux quatre blocs un peu la
dame 1 ou là pour prendre non d'en
prendre six d'abord d'emprunt six échecs
ça ça malheureux sa manière erronée ce
qui m'a fait notre amie là je crois que
c'est matt c'est notre force et je donne
du matériel si faite aux riffs 7 iliad
en france et 8 échecs donc déjà je
récupère le matériel et s'il fait rage
suite
il ya peut-être tout reprendre 4 et ça
c'est la mauvaise nouvelle pour les pour
les blacks pour les noirs pour prendre
quatre puisque après pions prend en plus
ce cavalier peut pas bouger parce que il
ya échec après puis on prend il ya
qu'amélie g5 et en menace damas trois
échecs suivi du mathan h7
le fait quand même
alors pour prendre quatre à l'air très
très fort on va le faire
à noter que je peux aussi faire cavaler
j'ai ça il ya aussi des cinq qui
récupère le cavalier peut pas bouger
mais bon on va faire d'abord calmer les
g5
à noter qu'un coup comme tours 6e marche
pas parce que je gagne la tour s'est
vite aussi et s'il boucle à tour ses 8
il se fait mater barrage 3 damas 7
maintenant si fait deux tours 8
il ya quand même peut-être dame g6 qui
menacent matt suite des cinq mois je
vais récupérer le cavalier donc j'ai
qu'une qualité de retour de retard avec
une attaque qui continue ong au moins
deux sages et peut-être plus j'ai
peut-être beaucoup plus attention il
faut que je fasse gaffe sur des cinq il
ya attention mais c'est pas forcément
grave on h 2
ce qui serait pas mal c'est d'avoir un
moyen d'amener cette tour à l'attack
aussi mais je crois pas qu'ils aient
moyens alors échec que roy j'évite
damage cet échec roi est fluide damas
huit recettes d'un projet cette robe
rouge c'est pas gagné encore hein c'est
pas gagné je peux aussi faire je peux
aussi faire tour dames g6 déjà dans un
premier temps moi je me lasse mathis il
est là des scènes marche parce qu'il
peut pas bouger ce cavalier il est cloué
que les bougies père le hyper le
calvados et je récupère au moins la
qualité et déjà c'est déjà énorme
ok donc je vais faire des cinq pour voir
parce que et après la prise il pourra
pas reprendre de la tour a causé la
turquie attaquer et s'y reprendre de la
dame s'est tour ici peuvent avoir un
rôle décisif après trois sets ça faisait
un moment que j'avais pas pu jouer une
attaque un peu sympa un petit coup des
cinq là je les aime bien en plus ça
prend une case
ouais 3 à broc et 3 c'est jouable
rien à dire c'est jouable
3 est jouable
est-ce que j'ai pas intérêt à jouer des
six ici plutôt que de faire ce que j'ai
dit parce que des six jeux menace damage
cette dame h8 maths parce que des six
jeux contrôler la case ossètes et je
contrôlais vii
je crois qu'il n'y a pas de défense sur
puis on prend et chaque croix h2 je
crois qu'il ya rien tout calcul il faut
que je paye ne faut pas que je me trompe
évidemment comme cavalier ou sept qui
peut jouer
d si ces cavaliers 7 pour les noirs rail
pas se tromper faut pas se tromper à
prendre et on va prendre pour voir alors
prise roi h 2
l'opposition est très compliqué ici
alors ça ça doit perdre je pense je
crois que ça perd alors déjà on peut
faire ça pour gagner un peu de temps et
shake shake shake shake shake
j'ai pas fait ce que je voulais en fait
je crois
échec sur cavaliers aux cinq sont re 5
je peux tout simplement faire cavalier 3
et prendre ici est-ce qu'il ya pas mieux
il faut aussi que je vois si y'a pas
mieux à temps il ya c'est un matelas
elle signe je crois que c'est matt je
vérifie à hesdin le 6 matches à noter
que s'il venait à ses 5 c'était mieux
parce que je crois qu'il y avait
maintenant il ya pas match seront ici il
y avait pas matt aut 5e c'était pas mal
cinq jeux peuvent être faire cavalier
échec peut-être tout reprendre dans
prend est en tout cas ce qu'ils ont fait
pas d'âme et l'attaquent continuer
hockey à une belle partie d' attaque là
je crois là c'est une partie haletante
allez fais plaisir cette partie là on a
marqué encore un point de point alors on
en est où sont pas c'est pas top top
alors décidément on joue de plus en plus
mal cette semaine et le père fait 2011
allez
aristide on va jouer avec des cinq à les
changer un peu on n'a pas joué encore
aujourd'hui d'amd 6
on vous face à aristide à les qualifs 6h
3h 3 3 3 à 3 3 6 6 1 6
p5 un gain de temps et placer mon cas
belmont fois en 17 points j'ai cinq
points gsm que j'estime que j'ai cenco
que 17 sans doute un tout simplement ici
c'est simple les prendre il faut prendre
ok
les quatre nouvelles cavaliers bon ici
je peux prendre ici ça casse tout et là
aussi ça casse tout non peut-être fou
aux cinq recettes recettes c'est bien
alors une petite échec ici pour éloigner
le roi une petite tour assez vite pour
contrer les tours pour prendre pour
prince où la ouais mais non je ne peux
pas ça peut marcher ça ouais presque on
a l'impression quand même bon allez tant
pis hop
alors il faut sortir loin font des leurs
au centre sava
ouais il faut démonter ce cavalier assez
mal joué ces quatre là ça va pas parce
que câble est obligé de jouer et donc il
va perdre 4 puis les pions à pression
tellement faible partout qu'il faut
prendre ça peut pas marcher
cavalli est enfermé donc là on va gagner
en mettant en exergue tout simplement
jouer h56 voir ça veut dire que les
blancs n'ont pu avoir de coup de coeur
il peut pas sortir voilà est obligé de
le sacrifier s'en rend compte
mais bon il suffit d'aller bloquer le
pion en c est le fou joue un rôle ici
pour contrôler les cases c'est
facilement de les nier bon bien il faut
je tiens beaucoup d'attentes tiens
plus prise échec chez les pions pour
essayer de faire maths plus vite on va
jouer échec alors il faut faire
attention aux pattes évidemment
le pote potes
bon c'est pas très rigolo qui poussent à
là bon me fait pas confiance pour gagner
sa bombe est arrivé peut-être raison un
peux me tromper mais bon on va faire un
bien fou là c'est mieux jouer un coup de
roi et ses maths
ok bon pas très rigolo la fin
allez on vous face à cadas on va changer
la tiens on va jouer à vis et 4 détroit
qui allait provoquer là il peut pas
prendre parce que sinon il se prend en
fout pranger cette wii 2 ok prise
detroit une surprise pas sûr que laisse
trop de morts ok
c'est peut-être la dernière partie sans
doute ce qui reste que neuf minutes 40
voilà donc si vous nous rejoignez on est
en direct tout le 30
combien 34e 35e épisode diagonale télé
sur leach s alors des trois peut-être
attaqué ça oui il va jouer cinq d'accord
ok donc on va pas faire comme ça on va
faire on va faire caler des deux
contrôles et la case de 4 pour empêcher
des os 4 faire attention ici si on n'est
pas trop faible dans ça va ça a l'air
d'aller
on va peut-être on va jouer avec la 3d 4
ici tout cas essayer comme cali des deux
là ça protège b3 sava s'affaiblit pas
trop où je pense
alors ces deux beckham et v4 rouge
attend les quatre très bien
la question c'est ce qui peut jouer
cavalier c3 ce que ça attaque la dame et
e26 faut prendre puis on prend ouais
ouais ça c'est bien joué qu'elle f4
évidemment way que les quatre hommes
bons coups faire attention ici allez hop
commencé à s'activer un peu
il joue et ça c'est de contrôler un peu
des trois l'idée c'est d'essayer de voir
si on peut pas jouer 3 pour chasser ce
cavalier poisson peut pas parce que
après prise prise il ya le pion détroit
qui qui seraient aux prises derrière
mais bon on peut y avoir des thèmes sur
la colonne est fait il faut pouvoir
dépasse tactique ici mais pour l'instant
les noirs sont bien ils ont aussi un
passé un bon cavalier en f4 c'est bien
c'est bien pour eux ça c'est bien pour
les pour les noirs alors si ça a été
fait
faut que j'arrive à jouer le 3 je peux
pas tolérer ce cavalier là c'est pas
possible il faut que je joue au 3
donc allez ici c'est pour protéger
ok donc la bombe pas trop le choix il
faut prendre
et là je peux jouer ce que laissait 5b
6b système cawi les 3 est pas mal aussi
faire kg 3 si j'arrive à chasser ce
cavalier peut-être à un peu mieux on est
encore en défense attention à pas faire
de grosses gaffes faut 6 ok allez aux 3
donc là il ya peut-être prise prise
logique est là le problème c'est que si
aaf ainsi fait prise prises s'il cueille
les bouges il va perdre f5 parce qu'il
ya la tour donc à peut-être pas à
prendre du coup mais elle s'y prend pas
qu'est ce qui va se passer
attention attention on ne nie pas ce
qu'il peut se passer des trucs
alors il prend que j'ai deux d'accord ça
ça paraît bien voire même très bien
c'est un bon coup il ya rien à dire
j'ai joué trop vite le plus envisagée
cavalli francs mais la f4 de toute façon
mon voile quand même un peu un peu aux
halles ou être l'un il est il est malin
je suis pas bien ici alors prise à 1,3
bon alors c'est là qu'il faut peut-être
réfléchir
ouais il faut que je reprenne pas le
choix il faut que je reprenne dame en
g53
ouais ouais il faut que je soulage un
peu la pression ici il n'ya pas fou à
trois ris si j'ai envie de faire flouer
3 pour cette dame là partent loin et ici
j'ai envie de ce recueil hk travail
échec
on sort de là alors si fait le 4 a donc
là cavalier f5 et c'est moi maintenant
qu'un cavalier à 25
tout à l'heure c'est lui qui avait un
clavier à 24 maintenant c'est moi chaque
année 1,5
waouh
alors échec si c'est bien s'il fait ou
g5 kabylie province 6 sur fou j'ai cinq
cavaliers prend 1,6 ou msa gagner voilà
c'est bon ça doit gagner pour moi ça ça
devrait gagner alors je peux faire d'un
échec
je sais pas si c'est bien madame échec
parce que s'il prend le cavalier seimat
roger 6 donc ça se complique la vie
disons alors ici je peux faire cavalier
g6 échec je peux faire dame prend aussi
d'emprunt elle est d'abord pour voir ça
grouille et de maths partout ici alors
peut-être d'un échec peut-être cavaliers
chèques qu'elle allait prendre tout
simplement de les prendre
ce matin six échecs et mat
ouais victoire là bas on finit bien on
finit bien je trouve
on finit bien après un début difficile
on finit pas trop mal donc faire mieux
mais bon alors je n'insiste pas parce
qu'il reste qu'une minute
donc ouais voilà on fait une perf
moyenne mais bon on a remonté quand même
donc à 2011 de pertes à l'heure de 1087
ça reste moyen mais c'est pas trop mal
parce que le voir et sur le score ici
voilà ça très très mal démarré notamment
une partie c'est dommage on a fait un
mauvais placement de souris mais bon
c'est correct
on a fait une bonne partie alors donc
qu'est ce qui se passe au tout début
c'est une zone à zoo ou 2238 qui en tête
qu'à leurs biens cinquante deux 52
points waouh
bravo à lui il fait une perf à 2567 avec
un taux de victoire à 79% et bien
gros tournois parce qu'il aille à rien
perdu eh ben je sais pas comment il fait
bravo aprilia qui ya abou yahia qui fait
une perf à 2297 web bombay si on avait
été en forme aurait peut-être pu
peut-être pu jouer en tête du cou alors
donc enzo ya zoo a réussi à faire comme
il n'a fait deux points du coup 54 c'est
beaucoup et c'est beaucoup beaucoup avec
19 parties jouées la russie a joué 19
battu des bons joueurs de 1428 1,2400 il
as well as une grosse grosse réussite là
pour une zone naso qu'il emporte
largement et les neuf points de plus que
le deuxième c'est beaucoup avec dix neuf
partis deuxième abou yahia et puis on va
peut-être regarder la partie de maxime
vachier lagrave
alors françois p j'ai vu deux trois
coups que j'aurais pas du tout pensé à
faire d'accord mais c'est pour ça que on
apprend ensemble quelques quelques idées
pour s'améliorer un peu puis trouver
d'autres idées aux échecs ensuite donc
phoenix qui à 2490 fait une perf à
presque deux mille six cent c'est
beaucoup c'est très bien et donc phoenix
il a fait là aussi galaga perdu aucune
partie c'est assez impressionnant et
nous on termine assez loin 306 ac 1-2 au
niveau du score du classement c'est bien
moins que la semaine dernière on avait
réussi beaucoup mieux mais c'était du
3-2 c'était pas du 5 3 par contre au
nombre de partis on n'a pas joué
beaucoup on n'a joué que 13 1 à 6 de
moins que le premier donc à du pouvoir
terminer des parties beaucoup plus
courtes savoir c'est ça qui ce type de
tournoi c'est à la fois c'est bien parce
qu'on joue tout le temps mais évidemment
vous parle maintenant de partis donc
sportivement c'est pas toujours très
et bon un peu discutable mais mon repas
c'est important sur le principe c'est
quand même chouette de pouvoir jouer
enchaîner les parties
c'est une autre façon de jouer et puis
bon la première partie c'est dommage que
les uns peuvent en danger parce que
c'est un joueur fort on en aurait bien
aimé faire une bonne partie on n'a pas
rencontré d'adversaire très très fort on
a gagné en 2000 s'en vont c'est pas ben
voilà c'est pas un gros tournoi on a
fait beaucoup mieux notamment la semaine
dernière on a fait très beau deux très
gros tournois mais bon c'est quand même
bien on est content d'avoir joué pas
trop fatigué je passe en une heure de
plus je craquais en fait il faut pas que
je le dépasse 2 heures d'affilée parce
que je fume après je le sers mocky qui
fatigue alors qu'ils me proposent une
partie apparemment le petit dragon ouais
je vais peut-être trois plus de plus tôt
3 + 2 que 3 0 je préfère et puis on va
regarder la partie de maxime si vous
voulez bien quand même parce que maxime
vachier lagrave donc que viennent de
gagner
maxime achiraf vous rappelle si vous
connaissez pas si vous arrivez sur la
chaîne qu'on connaissait pas trop c'est
notre numéro un français qui fait qui
est dans le top 10 mondial quoique
actuellement je sais pas trop où il en
est mais j'ai gardé le détail mais il a
été numéro 2 mondial il n'y a pas très
longtemps donc il fait partie des tous
meilleurs joueurs du monde il s'est
qualifié in extremis pour ce tournoi des
candidats grâce à un désistement de
dernière minute
bon voila mais ça peut arriver était
juste le premier à pouvoir être qualifié
derrière bon voilà les résultats mais il
arrive frais et je l'avais dit au début
de ce tournoi ça pourrait être la
surprise parce que rappelez vous des
joueurs n'ont pas forcément préparé mais
justement quand l'esprit frais parce
qu'ils se sont peut-être pas trop
fatigué dans la préparation peuvent
parfois créé des surprises c'était le
cas de l'équipe du danemark au
championnat d'europe 92 voilà je vais
donner cet exemple qui avait gagné
championnat d'europe
alors qu'ils s'étaient pas qualifiés au
départ ils étaient venus à cause du
désistement de la yougoslavie
voilà c'était une très grande équipe du
danemark qui a été champion d'europe
alors que 4,6
d4 d5 et on a une française donc le
frenchman maxime jouer que je vous
contre une française cette sorte de pied
de nez web et ip on va jouer après si tu
veux on va jouer aux 5
ces cinq à trois reprises prise
cavaliers 7 h 4 alors ça je pense que
c'est encore à peu près théorique est
connu par contre sur quel de 7 h 4 ça me
parait vachement bien quoi ça veut dire
qu'il faut que je révise mes ouverture -
alors système halle 6 à l'orage 6 on
peut se demander ce qui se prend en cas
de prise ici quand même qu'est ce qui se
passe près ce prise d'un échec fou des
deux dames tron on peut jouer cavalier
ici échec fou ouais c'est une autre
partie mais on n'a pas fait ça en tout
cas
donc il ya eu h 6 tours b1 b6 il a
toujours pas pris en d4 au quai d'alger
4 alors forcément là donc ici attaque
sur le sur le flanc aux huit fou des
cinq échecs roi bouge alors ils ramènent
le fou pourquoi parce que sans doute
sinon les noirs je sais que c'est 4 et
le fou là il est coincé peut plus
revenir et en b3 il est très très mal il
deuil et peut pas y aura un pion donc
ici se fout il sera perdu a6b 5 il est
foutu
donc on peut pas après l'échec le
laisser en bessin c'est pour ça qu'il
revient de détroit s'agissant le voit
tout de suite fois six présences et 5
prises en d3 ce qui est curieux parce
que sa robe ça dédoublant les pions il
n'a peut-être pas le choix je sais pas
cavaler 17 et là les noirs décide de
jouer quel et 17 reprises maintenant et
simplement maxime revient d un assez bon
voilà c'est le truc et prend toujours
pas il n'a pas envie de prendre qu est
ce qui se passait en cas de prise ici
prise prise échec
et il faut quoi il faut faire quoi le
jour où f1 ok on peut jouer madame d2 ok
pourquoi pas aussi bizarres se prennent
pas il a joué damas cinq coups des deux
tombes et huit cavaliers aux deux c4 c4
qui rend ce fut à la fois qu'on essaie
ici allez droit à l'ale dame par contre
lui mais que par contre se fout et peut
peut-être un jour sacrifier de l'autre
côté on va voir un petit rock b6 même
ses deux tours h suite à quatre à huit
tours b 4 qu'avait laissé six attaques
la tour et maxime il joue ff4 c'est à
dire qu'il est prêt à donner sa tour
contre le cavalier qu à l epr en qui on
prend surtout reprend attention parce
que la tour serait peut-être un peu
coincé il aurait dame c300 d'autres
derrière et la tour peut pas bouger donc
ici cavaliers cette tour
wen est arrivé pour les challengers si
vous écoutez là il faut que je termine
quand même j'ai envie de voir cette
partie f5 et quand même la partie du
jour
damas six fou c'est un af cette fois
trois tacles donc un petit peu le
cavalier donc c'est un défenseur du roi
les bleus auront la possibilité un jour
ou l'autre de jouer g4 et prison f5 mais
il faudrait pouvoir éliminer le cavalier
parce que si les noirs prennent avec
lecavalier après on peut rien faire par
contre si se calla l'essonne après prise
en effet cinq prises dans prend le roi
va commencer à avoir des problèmes
8 et ça y est c'est le cas et
l'attaquent commence
c'est parti pour maxime après toute
cette préparation c'est un peu le thème
de la française les blancs arrive
attaqué à la loi est simple la il
reprend pas tout de suite en effet celle
qui fait cavalier g3 et on a un couple
cavalier dames contre au roi parce que
ça ça va tomber alors que le roi blanc
est plus tranquille puisque le cavalier
noir et derrière dans le camp noir il
n'est pas du côté blanc
dames 2 6 cavale et prend un échec on la
fuite bien sûr les blancs il refuse de
changer d'âme puisque le roi noir est
faible le caballero viennent de mener
4-3 g2 tout simplement prise en f4
d'emprunts à sept
cet échec pour un long des six l'idée
d'alliances des six clouage on menace
peut-être sinon peut pas là tout de
suite fiscale en attaque le pion des
cinq g5 un peu mon coup désespéré ici
les noirs envie sans doute de jouer g4
pour faire des dames f3 échec mais
simplement la prise en passant bien sûr
alors on a une française jouer contre un
français et la fameuse prise en passant
que comme une expression française
c'est quand même une partie assez
magnifiquement française cette superbe
partie cette superbe victoire de maxime
façade nepomniachi cavaler h scène et
simplement g7 est là
la partie se termine ici abandon des
noirs la position blanche est beaucoup
trop supérieur on menace de faire dames
il n'y a pas d'effets en satisfaisant
que les blancs et or peuvent essayer de
l'empêcher mais il ya trop de il ya trop
de menaces derrière pour réussissent
pour prendre le cavalier 17 et menacé
des maths etc
il ya aussi des possibilités de faire
des dames et fuite puisque sur cavaliers
prend puis on prend rohff une dame si la
dame projet scène par exemple donc là en
fait opposition blanche est beaucoup
trop écrasante avec un roi noir qui est
sous pression
un pur g7 qui file à dam 1.5 qui peu
avancé un pion dessin qui va tomber et
c'est un superbe partie de maxime
vachier lagrave ici face à nepomniachi
et qui donc se positionne de manière
très claire maintenant pour vraiment
pourquoi pas gagner ce tour lundi
candidat et il serait dans ce cas là en
position d'aller affronter m'amuse car
scène dans un match championnat du monde
avec un français dedans du jamais vu
ça serait vraiment exceptionnel serait
bien sûr une très bonne chose pour la
france
alors ici en ip le petit dragon et théo
d'autres player je crois que là on
repeat j'ai jamais joué c'est pas voilà
donc je vais je vais jouer henri p si
vous voulez bien allée henri p saluant
ripper
alors hyper chaleur j'ai réussi à faire
32e mais bon c'est embêtant quand même
pourquoi est ce que tu es le bug au
début tu es mis en ayant perdu comme
activité lorsque tu as juste pas été
redirigée vers ta partie ouais à l'eos
5d 3 un très bon résultat du perche ever
donc qui nous dit qu'il a fini 32e ce
qui est vraiment exceptionnel cavaliers
m6 bravo à hyper shaver pour ce résultat
moi je fus des six et qui sait si ce
peut être allez petit rock
alors est-ce qu'on joue à 4 ici on envie
hein c'est le coup qu'on a envie de
jouer puis on prend pions prend que les
g5 on peut jouer tout huit
intermédiaires et puis non ça a pas
l'air bon donc quand même vite ou aux
quatre prises prise pas n'est pas
quelque chose ici non
à jouer donc tours 8
alors pourquoi le stream et surimi nos
échecs de la part du perche et bob et
parce que c'est aussi une chaîne
diagonale tv en fait ni nos chèques
c'est même la chaîne je dirais
historique puisque des gonades tv a pu
continuer à vivre après 2003 2004 sur
imineo d'abord en vod puis c'est
basculer youtube il donc de temps en
temps c'est normal de faire quelques
stream j'en ai fait aussi j'avais fait
le championnat de france rapide féminin
sur une riche cheikh ainsi que la moitié
du championnat du festival de perpignan
oc ont mis le hayon prend 2018
c'était aussi sur mignot chic voilà donc
c'est une chaîne nationale tv voilà
savoir à ça alors ça ça me donne un pion
aux quais et là j'ai pas si on va pas
jouer 3 quand même sinon on va prendre
non parce que trois yaka blake 3-6 jouer
3 qualif 3 ne crois pas qu après puis on
prend c'est pas terrible il vaut mieux
prendre des quatre c'est mieux on prend
le pion central alors là on a deux gros
avantages on a pris un pion central et
on a la peur de fou en plus une paire de
foucque et pas dans n'importe quelle
position ici alors
[Musique]
on va jouer tiens on va jouer dame eux
puisqu'on parle de père de fourdin me
cinq nations mais la smat tout
simplement à il a simplement oublié
donc là on a une batterie end à mfou et
iliad me prend h2 donc ses échecs et mat
merci henri p merci henri p allez donc
jantscher je crois que pareil j'ai pas
joué face à rpv vb ça me dit rien donc
je vais jouer avec lui si vous voulez
bien
voilà donc voilà et sinon la suite avant
les stream vous allez sur la chaîne
diagonale tv donc c'est bien d'avancer
de déconnade tv imineo échec voilà comme
ça mais vous risquez pas de rater quoi
alors que les psys ce qu'est ce que nos
âges et si ça devrait faire un g7
geci cependant pas que je traîne trop
allez petit rock
quatre des six cavaliers deux c6
à 6 une petit coup de pions ouais alors
ça c'est ambigu parce que les noirs
jouent à cinq et on contrôle la case b4
donc ça me permet d'avoir un cavalier
qui soit viande b4 soit bien c'est celle
qu'en évitant b4 non c'est ce que je
vais faire je vais aller en a six après
ce cavalier peut choisir d'aller ici ou
là ouais c'est pas mal ça ce que je sens
mon four gic la troupe ans pas sûr donc
je fais cavaillé b4 ça contre la casse
des 5
ça attaque un peu des trois et ce
cavalier paille pataca kelly à 2
ouais ok il ya deux possibles alors j'ai
envie de faire des scènes que
je m'étire quoi ici j'ai envie de faire
aux 5 le saigne pour fixée au 4 et
peut-être peut-être pour fêter ça n'est
rien ouais alors ça c'est ambigu ce
qu'on joue et on peut prendre aussi mais
plus qu alger 4 je pense non alors des
cinq prises prise
ouais des cinq a l'air bien allez hop on
y va
vous profitez vous profitez de cette
alors ici on peut prendre du plomb on va
prendre du plomb
en prise alors là je vais peut-être
prendre du plomb ici pour éviter voilà
pour que ma tour défendre un peu pour
éviter des problèmes à base d'oeuf ou
gsm ce genre de choses alors prise
qu'est crise prises fou des deux
il n'y a pas foule cinq ici est
intéressant on pouvait simple comment
ils défendent et j'ai envie de faire
face à quatre chefs au sein d'un b 3 ok
échec kg 4
on prend un chèque je bouge c'est celle
que c'est quoi l'idée à oui d'accord il
faut prendre b4 ce que ça me gêne
vraiment oui on va prendre connaissent
pas grave on joue et ça une 4 secondes
contre 1h30
fou 3 ou f3 falls 3 x 3 x f38 je sors de
là de l'ata qui si j'attaque détroit
s'il prend le cas tu reprends j'ai
quinze secondes mais j + 2
lorsque le string marche toujours bien
oui je regarde quand même prise
c'était chouette rite ok ouais tout
reprendre c'est bizarre c'est bizarre à
noter que sur dame c4 crois qu'il ya
tour ici tout simplement
quant à la dame est maintenant il ya
d'amd celles qui doivent faire maths
bien qu'ils m'en reste que vous n'avez
pas tout à fait maths parce que peut
jouer encore ici échec tour f 2 mais bon
disons qu'il ya plus de il ya plus de
place pour le ya plus de place pour le
roi ok victoire non pas pas de revanche
alors il ya hétérodoxes dragon et puis
il ya le petit dragon et des rucks
plaignants on va jouer des trois plus de
cheveux choisi le 3 + 2 allée le petit
dragon alors le petit dragon allez c'est
parti pour le contre le petit dragon
avec des quatre matchs auquel m6
ailleurs on joue avec ses 5 les 5 à 6 je
prends je vais prendre pourquoi
fou fait des six g63 au kef où les 7 du
rock
c'est à l'heure normale
alors ici qu'est ce qu'on fait les
scoops et damas cinq des huit peut-être
trouvé où tour à cette non bêtise
peut-être calais b si saleh veut un peu
de pression là-dessus on vise aussi un
peu la casse et 4 où ça c'est risqué
alors qu'havas les prend
calais prend qu'à l'épreuve prince ou
princesse alors bon je crois que c'est
un peu
trompé par des chiens policiers
maintenant je prends un jeu prend mais
je prends j'ai eu à la fin j'ai une
qualité de plus ça va
[Musique]
ça c'est le problème de jouer à des
coups comme b3 en façade une volaille
pas le choix face d'une dame comme ça
alors tut tut tut tut dames 4 pour
centraliser la dam dam des cinq dames 4
à leurs biens
d'emblée me talach bien mesdames
quatremer mieux comme étant le 4 à la
prescience sur le pion à deux ont créé
des menaces cavalli gsm qui ça c'est
curieux parce qu'ils défendent pas donc
on va prendre ce prise ah oui d'accord
il n'a pas la faille à tours où un il va
prendre le set ok d'accord donc la
rejouer simplement kg pas de qualité en
fait je crois j'ai une qualité mais non
j'ai rien du tout d'actualité du tout
comme des scènes way tomber 8
voyez une qualité l'avant ce nom
j'ai eu un petit mirage alors tombé cas
peut-être l'idée c'est de ici c'est de
pouvoir jouer kobe 700 gêné matour je
peux aussi jouer ces quatre peut-être c4
est intéressant aussi joué sept 7 peut
pas être mauvais ces quatre peut-être
mieux ok alors a laissé 4 on peut tous
un jeu les pieds s'activent encore
faut-il qu'elle joue
ouais j'ai pensé
5 alors après tout ça est prise l'esprit
du coup d'en prendre un point c'est bien
sinon allez d'emprunt pression sur a2
ouais
le petit dragon réfléchi 36 contre 49
on reste avec des pièces active le fouet
et sans doute un peu mieux que le
cavalier ici quand il ya des pions sur
les deux ailes ça devrait être un tout
petit peu mieux
peut-être tout reprendre été plus précis
on va être en croire c'était mieux
c'était mieux de faire retour prend ici
alors ouais ouais donc pis si bon on
peut prendre deux noms qui se passe si
je prend 1,2 à sa mère très bien
maintenant je peux pas attention hop là
il faut prendre à yop
on réfléchit pas trop on va faire tomber
deux ici tra un jour et fuite et on va
jouer avec f5 tient 7 6
des cinq des 4
alors rendez 6,6
3 2 ap
ces gens
ouais cheikh davance broxeele filtre ici
échec alors là on peut jouer ça c'est
quand même très intéressant
si cheikh
les to qui tombe là alors il check
on va pouvoir prendre ça tient échec
j'ai fait une petite erreur pour h 2
alors ici on joue ici à pousser les
pions et chez moi je vois de là
peut-être ça fait nul sauf que je perde
aussi
[Musique]
alors il check cheikh saad a fait un nul
c'est nous pas sûr pour cheikh
alors il faut pas faire de bêtises
échec
et ça fait nul in extremis ainsi très
dur à gagner en fait d'un rencontre
autour ça gagne mais c'est très très dur
en hockey belle partie c'était un peu
tendu j'aurais dû la gagner sans doute à
la finale deux tours là j'ai pas été
assez technique mais le parti de du
petit dragon à les auteurs d'exploits
year et ouais je n'ai pas joué alors
attends donc supérieure à ces trois
héros ben c'est plutôt eux trois plus de
brel blanche choisi 3 + 2 r fait je
préfère parce que je suis trop foot
robot 23 0 vous avez vu hier il n'y a
pas que la fatigue gagne et aussi le
fait c'est une cadence qui me convient
pas je suis pas bullet du tout alors des
3 0 c'est pas tout à fait du bullet mais
c'est quand même chaud c'est très très
chaud
à pourquoi j'ai roque est obligée là
alors qu'elle allait prendre prises pour
8 allée prendre 6 obligé ça non plus du
coup bizarres des fois moins
alors si c'est peut-être un pauvre 600
ch sans avoir canalise b5 hockey a
laissé cinq
toutefois si si si voilà pour contrer le
four b2 comme ces sept on défend
bessette à cause du coup j'ai de là-bas
alors ok donc là on prend tout
simplement ça devrait aller
alors ensuite c'est à nous les envie de
faire ça
pcsi c'est mieux ton mouton alors aussi
ça n'attaque c42 campion tout simplement
alors maintenant tourner vite ça doit
être pas mal calé des deux qu'elle ait
des deux caves animaux sont permis de
caler au sun qui a [ __ ] en baisse est
d'un premier set
non ok 5 et jouable la caisse est
jouable
ne se forge est ici
on apprend bessette il d'en prendre fo
prend et à la fin ça perd le cavalier en
fait le fait que le travail soit attaqué
permet d'envisager ce coup alors ici des
5 mes5 ailleurs jouable encore des cinq
prises prise à la b5 les cinq alors très
très bon parce que le pion n'est pas
prenable toujours à cause de ce cavalier
un cavalier qui qui se met en prise
ouais ouais et donc que là je te
laisserai pas la prochaine fois je te
laisserai pas ok donc ouais ouais
alors il ya cavaliers detroit 1 ici que
les détroits cas l'air de tout n'y en
ait pas tout reprendre dewey qu'elle et
détroit mais ce que je pouvais pas le
faire pendant ces trois des cinq c'est
prendre les scènes non non c'est
horrible c'est l'homme qui me permet de
le faire ok calais prend et oui mais un
petit échec intermédiaire quand même
qu'il va falloir gérer pas forcément
très grave mais il ya tout reprendre des
deux à la fin qui est pénible aussi à
une vue alors attention il faut prendre
mais à la fin on ya tous ces quatre cas
l'air de garder du matériel ah oui très
bien mais là il ya là à
non non non alors peut-être tour
attendez vite c'est pas mal tendez ne
s'est pas mal et oui j'ai six le fou
pour à paga voilà mais le fou peut pas
garder les deux cases il peut pas garder
la caf c2 et la case à 8
donc maintenant il suffit d'amener le
roi aujourd'hui faire tourner deux
échecs
h m ces bêtes à temps des deux échecs
bon c'était encore plus facile ça fait
rien attention pas faire de bêtise ça va
pas être facile à gagner ça rodez 5
procès quatre échecs les rois ces trois
dans la set
qu'est ce qui se passe là le fou n'a pas
de case je vais encore me retrouver avec
beaucoup de pions mais contre moi mais
ça devrait aller là je pense parce que
c'était vraiment rester un pion qui va
freiner les blancs voilà donc je gagne
le fou voilà
mais là ce devrait être insuffisant pour
les blancs je pense a prises
tout ici et maintenant madame leroy très
vite
tour 3 et ouais ça c'est la mauvaise
nouvelle parce que hélas et matt durant
alors j'ai une petite cloche le petit
dragon une prochaine fois je te laisse
pas faire donc alors ok alors été au box
et pire pvb bon on a déjà joué
bon alors il est 23 heures bon je vous
propose que je vous propose qu'on
s'arrête là parce que là je fatigue
quand même je fatigue et alors la finale
dames contre tours est archi gagnante je
les gagnants de mai dernier tournoi oui
bien sûr aller gagner en tournée
d'accord 1 j'ai dit qu'elle était
difficile à gagner même contre tours ça
gagne mais même laurent frayssinet qui
est quand même pas le dernier joueur
venu qui est quand même grand maître
international m'a dit encore récemment
il me lie que c'est qu'il m'a dit ça à
froid c'est au cap d'agde alors il ya
participé à la production avec diagonale
tv puis cech 24 l'ap de la
retransmission du cap échec et on s'est
revu à cette occasion puisque c'est
quand même un ami que je connais depuis
longtemps et on en a parlé de ça il me
dit non c'est très dur à gagner que
voilà il même les grands maîtres du mal
je suis dire c'est surtout en blitz
voilà enfin tout cas voilà donc il faut
que faut vraiment travailler cette
finale à fond pour pouvoir la gagner
essayé de la jouer contre stockfisch
niveau 8
voilà simplement pour vous rendre compte
de la difficulté vous la mettez sur son
lit chess là vous allez dans outils je
vous donne le truc pour vous entraînez
vous allez dans l'outil vous allez dans
éditeur de position voilà vous videz
l'échiquier vous mettez vous mettez la
dame
le roi contre roy et tours voilà comme
ça
par exemple ici ses échecs ses hauts
blancs de jouer et vous fait continue
depuis cette position vous choisissiez
jouer contre l'ordinateur vous
choisissez à partir de la position
niveau 8
vous choisissez de jouer avec les blancs
là il vous faut gagner ça mais bon
courage
voilà je vous souhaite bon courage sais
c'est pas facile quoi c'est pas facile
d'aller voir que vous allez vous allez
souffrir pour la pour l'emporter à moins
que vous la connaissez bien et elle a
gagné le tournoi contre joueur c'est pas
la même chose à younes ryan joue un peu
s'il vous plaît hétérodoxes player mais
on a déjà joué non bon allez je une
dernière partie aller face à hétérodoxe
ah ben c'est parce qu'il veut prendre sa
revanche
allez vas-y hétéro d'autres player ok
allez on va jouer avec des 5 voilà que
je connais pas du tout en détail
simplement je me suis mis à jouer ça
récemment et j'ai eu des quelques bons
résultats donc je me la joue un peu sa
note et position un peu plus ça permet
de jouer 5 sans doute sans doute qu'ici
les c6
pour cette dernière partie de la journée
voilà j'espère ça vous a plu en tout cas
et puis donc là je vais pas jouer demain
je sais pas si je vais jouer vendredi ou
samedi je sais pas par contre il ya un
il ya un tournoi diagonale tv ça
s'appelle un pion non alors il faut
prendre pions prend que les prends ou
cavaliers prend directement à l'est et
donc yann d'albi cent et les dimanches
dimanche donc faut prendre pu comprendre
je me prends c'est bien dimanche a donc
j'ai programmé un bis 3 + 2 voilà donc
vous êtes invités à jouer s'il vous
plaît crocs
dimanche donc vous retrouver simplement
vous cherchez dans l'équipe diagonale tv
et il est si listés dans le forum
voilà dans communauté équipe vous
cherchez diagonale tv si vous n'êtes pas
inscrit déjà dedans et simplement vous
vous cherchez donc
les gonades tv dans la partie diagonale
tv dans l'équipe diagonale tv dans la
page de l'équipe vous allez trouver le
forum et dans le forum il ya le lien
vers le tournoi de dimanche à 14h30
voilà deux heures de 3 + 2 quand tu l'as
airlines pour diffuser ton point de vue
du tournoi sud de france alors c'est
quoi le qu'est ce que c'est le tournoi
sud de france le tournoi par équipe de
club c'est ça qui est prévue en avril
oui mais si je joue je fais lie
normalement oui là je me suis décidé à
faire ça je vais pas je pars était alors
m6 avec lecavalier
ouais ça ça me permet de jouer toujours
là et je suis très content s'il me prend
le fou en fait je continue débarrasser
de ce fou qui est derrière mes pions
noirs l'a fait je suis content et je
suis pas mécontent
vous êtes alors on a quoi là on en a on
est avec un point de plus échec
bon c'est 7
vous c4
alors ça ça te permet de f 5 et 6 fois
f3e 4 et or mauvaise nouvelle le fou n'a
plus de cases donc un fois je trouve
être un peu forcée voilà faut se trouve
être un peu forcé et est ce qu'on va
faire ici maintenant alors amelia voilà
faut 2 on va récupérer le pion aux 5
du coup et se fout et a été mis un peu
en jeu là il me semble
alors tour
allez je vais prendre ton des cinq a été
fait à 5
alors maintenant peut-être parce qu'il
faut faire ça c'est pas sur ce que j'ai
pas intérêt à jouer plutôt ça allait je
sors de sort de là parce que mon
cavalier n'a pas trop d'avenir et j'ai
gagné autant que j'ai même pas vu
ok bah voilà donc c'était la dernière a
joué arrêté parce que vraiment se
fatiguer je fatigue donc pas demain
demain je pense pas non je ferai pas de
blitz pas de pas de stream
peut-être vendredi savons ici le
vendredi j'étais en forme la semaine
dernière je verrai ça son choix
meilleure forme et tourna d'une heure
c'est sûr que 2h 3h sa fatigue quand
même simplement voilà en tout cas
victoire aujourd'hui de maxime h la
grave
donc je vous dis à bientôt sur des
modèles tv merci d'avoir suivi
et puis a très vite et portez vous bien
ciao ciao